[Musique]
sur la place Saint-Pierre noire de foule
au milieu du déploiement d'un faste
Royal le pape Jean 23 a été conduit du
Vatican à la basilique qui pendant
quelques jours doit abriter son ombre
[Musique]
coucher sur un lit d'apparaît à bras
d'homme vêtus des ornements pontificaux
miroitant de pourpredor le pape défunt
entouré de gare de Suisse et de garde
noble semblait flotter au dessus des
têtes innombrables de ce peuple qu'il
avait tant aimé et qui le lui rendait
bien
[Musique]
à l'intérieur de la basilique la
dépouille mortelle de Jean XXII devait
être placée sous le baldaquin de bronze
qui abrite l'hôtel de la confession
au-dessus de la tombe de la poutre c'est
là que pendant deux jours et demi il
recevra l'hommage public du monde
chrétien pendant ces 48 heures des
milliers des milliers de fidèles
défileront devant le cataphalt après
avoir attendu de zerze entière le moment
de sa genouillée devant celui qui fut en
même temps que l'esprit le plus
audacieux le cœur le plus simple et le
plus accessible
[Musique]
peu d'hommes auront connu un hommage
aussi universel avec Jean 23 un grand
pape vient de disparaître
[Musique]
la traversée de l'Atlantique par un
hélicoptère solitaire est un exploit qui
n'avait jamais été réalisé un
hélicoptère lourd de l'armée américaine
vient de combler cette lacune 35 heures
de vol l'ont conduit par le Canada le
Groenland l'Islande et l'Écosse jusqu'au
Bourget
là son périple devait lui valoir d'être
remarqué au milieu d'autres hélicoptères
aux performances remarquables comme le
désert Sikorski la gruevalente de
l'Allemagne de l'Ouest qui promène avec
la plupart faites aisance des camions
dans le ciel
l'aviation et l'espace tiennent en effet
salon ou Bourget le général de Gaulle a
inauguré cette grande manifestation à
laquelle participe 17 nations pour sa
part la France il y a dévoilé son futur
satellite ou voguera le successeur du
rate
[Musique]
le chef de l'État a pu admirer la
maquette de l'avion supersonique
franco-anglais Concorde dont les
États-Unis ont commandé sur plan 6
exemplaires
il a pu également assister aux
évolutions du Balzac
cet appareil français décolle et
atterrit dans un mouchoir de poche
il peut rester immobile ou reculé en
plein ciel ce qui n'empêche pas de voler
à deux fois la vitesse du son
le 25e salon de l'aéronautique est
ouvert dans ce supermarché de l'aviation
la France tient une des premières places
aucun de Mailly la vedette a été tenue
par la mx30 version française du chat
européen de 30 tonnes armée d'un canon
de 105 qui rentre avec une très grande
précision un obus à charge creuse
capable de percer tous les blindages la
mX 30 d'une très grande mobilité
franchite avec aisance un obstacle
vertical de 90 cm un fossé à bord franc
large de 3 mètres le laisse indifférent
ajoutons que sa parfaite étanchéité lui
permet de traverser les rivières par 2
mètres de fond voire 4 mètres avec un
équipement spécial comme aussi de
continuer de manœuvrer en zone
contaminée en cas de conflit atomique
à l'heure des fusées opérationnelles à
tête nucléaire la mX 30 permet au char
blindé de demeurer une arme de combat
fondamental
il flottante bouée laboratoire on ne
sait trop comment nommer cette étrange
champignon fiché dans la mer en rade de
Villefranche et sur lequel un
hélicoptère a récemment amené à ministre
cette construction dans le commandant
Cousteau et le promoteur et qui a
inauguré monsieur Gaston palevski
ministre délégué à la recherche
scientifique est actuellement unique au
monde
elle est composée d'un long tube
vertical contenant 4 étages de
laboratoire et s'enfonçant jusqu'à 52
mètres de profondeur ce qui rend
insensible au plus forte houle de la
Méditerranée sa partie supérieure qui
domine la mère de 10 mètres et qui
renferme le laboratoire des
enregistrements un ascenseur descendant
jusqu'à quelques 25 mètres au-dessus du
niveau de la mer conduite aux quatre
laboratoires où seront étudiés la
biologie sous-marine la température et
la constance des courants et ce qui
était jusque-là impossible avec un
navire océanographique observez tous les
phénomènes de l'océan d'une manière
continue et à un point donné en effet
cette bouée permet des prélèvements
continuels d'échantillons d'eau à tous
les niveaux et l'observation directe de
la vie de la mer par les vins hublots
répartis sur sa surface immergée
l'équivalent si l'on veut d'une station
météorologique mais au cœur de l'océan
[Musique]
envahi par le torrent formé par des
pluies incessantes la grotte de
foussoubi laisserait-elle ressortir les
cinq spéléologues qui s'étaient
aventurés sous ses vues malgré les
pompes malgré les travaux d'entreprises
pour détourner le torrent restaient-ils
après 5 jours d'absence une possibilité
de sauver les captives de la grotte art
des choix
le torrent est un enfin détourné les
sauveteurs purent s'enfoncés dans la
montagne avec leur scaphandre et leurs
canaux pneumatiques
fin de l'épreuve triste fin d'ailleurs
car si derrière Émile Chayette le
premier des rescapés remontait deux de
ses compagnons deux autres ne
reverraient plus le soleil de l'un de
ceux-là on ne remontrait qu'un cadavre
de l'autre on ne retrouverait aucune
trace
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rien ne semble désormais impossible à
l'athlète français Michel JAZY qui va
les record du monde sur commande et le
miracle dans tout cela c'est que jazine
n'a rien à Superman jazzy c'est monsieur
tout le monde avec un petit quelque
chose en plus c'est à dire le cran et le
désir de vaincre le tout saupoudré d'un
grand amour pour l'athlétisme cela
suffit parfois pour devenir un très
grand champion c'est presque la fin de
cette tentative contre le record du
monde du 2 mailles au stade Charléty il
passe il résistiblement son partenaire
Robert Baugé se finit chez désormais
l'une des qualités essentielles de
Michel JAZY qui pourrait croire en le
voyant sprinter qu'il est en train de
battre le record du monde des 2000
l'allure d'un spécialiste du 400 mètres
on ne sait pas jusqu'où ira Michel JAZY
sûrement vers un titre olympique l'année
prochaine
le deuxième Salon International de la
chasse photographique qui s'est ouvert à
Paris révèle un aspect nouveau de la
chasse
un chasseur il ne s'agit plus de tuer
les bêtes mais de les surprendre et de
les restituer vivantes sur une photo ou
sur un écran
[Musique]
mais remplacé par l'objectif d'une
caméra la carabine de précision ne fait
pas de cette chasse nouvelle un sport
mineur
[Musique]
il faut comme à l'autre de la patience
de l'habileté du courage et du
sang-froid
mais quelle joie aussi de rapporter des
tableaux de chasse vertigineux comme
l’ont fait Jacqueline et François sommer
de promoteur de ce nouveau sport un jour
en même temps que les girafes vous
pouvez découvrir les rites secrets de la
vie des autruches
un autre jour vous découvrez à bout
portant pour ainsi dire le plus
extraordinaire tableau vivant de la vie
de famille des éléphants
chasseur changez donc votre fusil
d'épaule il ne s'agit plus de tuer de
pauvres bêtes mais de les ramener vivant
[Musique]